for today's classic interview we're
going back to when i spoke to him levin
back in 2014
and he told us about the religious
gay conversion therapy that he i
sang experienced isn't even right really
was sort of
tortured through and suffered through
and this is relevant for a couple of
reasons number one
gay conversion therapy for children
continues to be banned in more and more
states and that's a good thing
we also have a vice president currently
in mike pence who although he never
actually stated he supports the use of
you know electro shock for gay
conversion or anything of the sort
he did previously say that he would be
okay with federal funding to
treat people that want to change their
sexual behavior
which is very often coded language that
the religious right likes to use
talking about behavior rather than
sexual orientation as if these are
merely issues of choice
so in that context we'll go back to my
interview from a few years ago with him
levin the topic of course
gay conversion therapy i'm joined today
by hayam
levin who has been actively campaigning
against so-called
conversion therapy for years and writing
about the subject
and haim your story is so interesting
and i want to kind of start at the
beginning you grew up as an orthodox jew
in crown heights brooklyn not very far
from where i live or from where our
studio is in fact
uh talk a little bit about your
background did you
always know that that you were gay did
you always identify as a gay man
hi david good afternoon um first of all
thank you for having me
and um that was pretty uh accurately
described and uh
so i mean that your question has a kind
of a couple of answers
in the sense that uh during my childhood
i
i had this confusion because i was uh
sexually abused by a relative for
for quite a number of years and for many
years afterward i believed that
this abuse that my my cousin had
inflicted upon me had actually been the
cause of my sexual orientation
now granted i grew up in a very devout
orthodox community in the sense that
in our schooling system we had no
reading no writing
no spelling no math no science no
history no formal
english secular subjects strictly bible
studies from nine to five every day
including sunday
so i didn't really know much about
science or about the world
i knew that there was like the gay
community out there in the village that
you know that was whatever and not
something that i was
connected to but i was inside i was
deeply troubled because i knew that i
was
attracted to people of the same gender
and i
you know and i kind of like just kept
pushing it away with the hope that well
you know maybe if
i study enough or if i pray enough uh it
will it will just go away
or you know something like that and i
was
uh really certain that uh
again because i had no outside no
knowledge
about this i was certain that if i could
overcome my sexual
abuse or my childhood then somehow i
could
change you know my my attractions and
that's kind of where jonah came in
because they were
they're the first ones to take that idea
and to
kind of magnify at times 10 and say yes
of course the reason you're
you're gay is because of your sexual
abuse it's also because you you had a
distant father and an overbearing mother
and
bottom line you know they said we could
change you so that was all i needed to
hear
to start right when i turned 18 i was
yeah so let's tell for our audience who
isn't familiar jonah is
jews offering new alternatives to
homosexuality
and hayam talk a little bit about when a
rabbi actually told you that there's a
group that specializes
in this whatever it was that that he
meant by this
presumably of course the so-called
conversion therapy
so you started going to i hesitate to
even use the term therapist but talk
about who it is that you started to see
and what those
sessions were like well there were um
it was kind of compounded there was um i
had uh
disclosed to this rabbi i mean it wasn't
i didn't really keep it much of a
massive secret in the sense that i never
identified as gay but people knew that i
was
struggling or you know oh you know i
guess the way
things in this community are like oh
yeah you know he's such a pity he has
problems but
i you know i i kind of confided in this
rabbi i said i don't know what to do
and he told me about jonah now i had
seen their advertisements in the jewish
press which is
uh a mainstream pretty ultra orthodox
right-wing
newspaper that that is read by everyone
including my parents every week
so when he told me jonah like i had
already heard of them but i never
you know so i i connected with them uh i
spoke to first the director mr arthur
goldberg
who um who when i met him he said you
know you
you must uh sign up for this program
called journey into manhood which is run
by one of their
sister organizations called people can
change uh he said that's the first step
that you have to do and we also
recommend
you know we and then after you do that
weekend um
you know we could start helping you out
here this was just around the time that
i was turning 18. so
i turned 18 on may 13th and then on june
1st i was headed to pennsylvania
to uh journey into manhood weekend with
a bunch of other
men um you know and it was kind of like
a very controlled environment where
you know i was frightened i had no idea
what to expect and
a lot of very weird and disturbing
things happen on those weekends and i've
spoken about a number of them
both uh you know in writing in my
articles i've also
i've also testified to them and i can
tell you this
uh you know what what definitely you
know in hindsight
i look back and i say you know something
was so wrong and that
uh it was the first time that i had
been interacting with other gay people
but it was also the first time that i
had been interacting with other people
who weren't
literally just like me from the crown
heights community
meaning there were other jews there but
i had never even talked to other jewish
people
even though they were technically
orthodox jews they weren't from our sect
um and one of the one of the the more
disturbing things that happened was that
there was a 63-year-old man
uh a widower an orthodox wither who
was on this weekend and after the
weekend
he would call me nonstop he was calling
me all the time
uh he wanted to talk you know he was
leaving me all these voicemails i kept
talking his calls
and the last time i saw him which was in
a group session
by jonah at jonah's headquarters in
jersey city
during this group meeting he admitted to
molesting three of his students two or
three i'm not sure the exact number
of his students in the in the religious
school where he came from
uh this never left the room and there
were 10 people in the room
and now putting it all together i'm a
survivor of
sexual abuse now it's become very clear
that jonah kind of jonah and these other
groups they treat
they treat gay people like pedophiles
they were treating pedophiles i mean i
have a friend whose father was an abuser
and before he uh before
his mom reported him he was told by the
directors of jonah don't report your
husband to us
don't don't report your husband to the
police send him to us and we'll treat
him and he'll be safe
and he'll be safe to be around your
other children and that for me
personally aside from the fraud aspect
of that like
this is like trying to pick something
that's not broken
in a lot of very you know dangerous ways
uh
the the irresponsibility to put
admitted pedophiles older people you
know without
in in contact with 18 year old kids uh
you know even though an 18 year old is
considered an adult it's still so
it's so reckless and well sure and of
course the i mean the premise that
both require the same type of treatment
is obviously patently absurd
so hey we don't have an unlimited amount
of time so there's a few other things i
want to touch on
what were the credentials of these
so-called therapists that you were
assigned to to work with
well they did actually didn't have
credentials they called themselves life
coach
coach life coaches now i had been seeing
a a female therapist
here in brooklyn and when i started
attending
jonah arthur goldberg told me it would
be better for me to see
a male therapist and he recommended
their life coach who works out of their
office mr allen downing
so talk about let's talk about that
because i think that that's just
you know it really epitomizes what it is
that's going on here
talk about this last meeting that you
had which you've spoken about and
written about
with the layers of clothing right so i
had been seeing mr
downing uh kind of sporadically uh for
about a year and a half
uh you know between monetary concerns
and
uh just you know this this this hard i
was like like in
and felt like i was in exile because i
wasn't changing yet i was doing all
these things to change
and i came to downing's office and he
you know he started off the session by
getting me to
uh to talk about now but before i before
i do that if you don't mind i'm just
going to step back and say that
you know part of the one part of these
the theories behind these things are
you know you have a broken masculine
image right or your your masculinity
needs to be repaired and so
he got he said well i want you to create
a few messages
that you feel to be true about about you
know about yourself
negative messages and as we created them
he said okay now i want you to say them
out loud he instructed me to stand in
front of a mirror and he said with you
know
say one message and take off a layer of
clothing now immediately i had known
which direction this session was headed
in and i told him i turned to him and i
said you know i'm really not comfortable
doing this
um this uh mr downing himself admits to
having what what he calls same-sex
attraction like otherwise known as gay
and um he you know i was like i'm not
i'm not comfortable taking my clothes
off in front of a man who's like three
times my age
locked in front of a mirror especially
given the fact that
he yeah i just it was it was very
uncomfortable but
i told him no uh his no
you know my no to him was not respected
in the sense that
he turned it back around on me and said
well why are you afraid what are you
afraid of
you know if you don't do this then
you're not going to be completing the
work
and that's that's the other trap that
they make which is oh
you didn't change because you didn't
work hard enough right it seems that the
entire thing is very carefully crafted
first to make it seem like you're an
outlier there's something we have to fix
and then if there's any resistance
whatsoever to the so-called treatment
that's prescribed
you're then blamed for being a pr part
of the problem or at least of not
fixing the problem that they've
indicated exists
right exactly and and you know it
essentially it ended
in my clothes were completely off i was
completely naked in front of him and he
instructed me to touch my private parts
as a as a
indication or symbol or something that
will
uh that would that would indicate me
taking
back my masculinity it's kind of similar
to what michael ferguson said in the
when we announced the lawsuit which was
had to do with the oranges and the balls
um you know it's all it's all kind of
these like ridiculous exercises that are
supposed to represent something bigger
um but you know again as a survivor of
you know four years of sexual abuse by
my
first cousin who was six years older
than me i've been spending i've spent
the last 10 years of my life
transitioning from victims to survivor
and this was a real
setback in a way because um i i tried to
exert my power and say
no like i don't want to do this this is
not right
right but it really wasn't respected and
i can say with certainty the most
offensive part to all this
is that we've been uh we've been in
depositions over the last few months and
repeatedly i've been asked to equate
that session with
you know sexual abuse of my childhood
which one was worse which one was more
traumatizing to you and like that's just
ridiculous but
that's that's you know it's not it
doesn't seem that they're denying
that this happens they're just defending
it absolutely
listen there's so much more we could
talk about unfortunately we are at a
time we're going to be following the
lawsuit we didn't get into the details
but as you mentioned there is a lawsuit
so we will follow it and we'll
definitely have you back on i can't
thank you enough for being here and
sharing your story
thank you david thank you this is viewer
supported independent media please
support our program by going to
davidpakman.com
membership and becoming a member today